a rescue George he was 2 years old he's
not just a friend he's family don't move
a muscle
are you crazy very funny you and I
laughing at your joke new guy he know
about he cry you can get up now
and check your diaper come on your
message about Georgie ok it's ok
as in mirrors he considerably bigger no
he's definitely bigger need to find
someone who knows exactly what the hell
this thing is
I found her no that's a lie technically
she found us what's happening to my
friend are you familiar with genetic
editing changes would be incredibly
unpredictable increased strength George
speed agility
sales and save the cane run Where's
George I need to see him he is dangerous
we've created the next chapter in
natural selection project rampage works
little science experiments running
around we meet
of course the wolf lives
this time we throw everything we can at
these things and get people the hell out
of that city let's go save the world
that's a big arm don't you know there
are other ways of dealing with people I
do know that yeah but that's not fun
okay what do we got I got our shooter
it's not just fear that's recognition
turns out some gang ambush them and
killed his brother it took me ten whole
years to track down these people for you
I'm gonna kill them all I got a hunch it
might be our guy
they've all got records armed robbery
rape assault now it seems like he's
going after everyone on his list I've
been expecting you
but just place the second shooter at the
scene so they had a little shootout in
the hall do you think you're done
that's one more
[Music]
pure no hesitation
is faster
working now light
you better be sure because that's a mom
dunk around your head it down
where are you
I love the devil cut our twist the
vengeance of hate
[Music]
and you find it in your heart to forgive
I can't
[Music]
you gotta check this out you place for
games anymore
yo what's this
Manji pick a character and you're that
person in the game Bethenny you went I
don't spend my life staring at a TV
screen it's my hair
wisdom was to me
oh my god marrying different people's
party
don't look at it I'm an overweight
middle-aged man wait a second where's my
phone we become the avatars which are
welcome to too much
this is a video game which means reach
f3 lives let's go I'm out watch your
step in here so gnarly we can help each
other I hate this game everybody else
got good stuff weakness Hey
yes cake is my weakness good weapons
valet what is that I think it means you
carry my weapons and give them to me
when I tell you to don't let this new
body get your butt woman we have to work
together I think it's a staring contest
who's good at staring and not blinking
I'm amazing at it
[Music]
I like can't even with this place
[Music]
get on my back
hell no I'll carry you come on I would
rather die on my gosh no I'm going down
[Music]
biggest pancake cake isn't that your
weakness something happening to me am i
shaking I'm not still black yes believe
me right
of course our boy here is a federal case
the mandatory minimum laws are very
simple
Jason is facing ten years in prison ten
years we need your son to help us make
arrests before we can help them reduce
his sentence I cut you outta here Wow
she's just going to mood assist you in
for me an introduction well what more
for us you will be treated like family
this of course includes your wife your
child what happens when everyone finds
out you're an informant they gotta come
after our families gentleman there is no
way I'm all that either side and dictate
our fates no way
every move that I make Jason will have
to live with for the next 10 years of
his life what if you don't live snitch
[Music]
[Music]
are you hurt people need to know that
the shaking is not over
we'll get hit again and that's going to
be a bigger monster
[Music]
my god the earth will literally crack
open you will feel it on the East Coast
I cannot emphasize this enough
you need to get out and let me now
if you can't
have you with you
[Music]
what generations this peaceful island
has been home to our family but beyond
our great danger is coming
legend tells of a hero who journey to
find that demigod Maui and together they
will save us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the hero of men it's actually Maui
shapeshifter demigod of the Windansea
hero of men I interrupt it from the top
your row of men go going on a mission
with some little girl did not see that
coming ocean is a friend of mine first
we got to go through a whole ocean a bad
horror
they're kind of cute
[Applause]
[Music]
got you back it's Maui
really blow dart in my butt cheek we're
going into the realm of monsters don't
worry it's a lot farther down than it
looks
[Music]
[Applause]
it was an accident accident why you keep
letting them back in you know why she
got it
[Music]
about you 17 years old were you gonna be
in four years I don't know you don't
find an alternative is you're gonna die
Society had given up on that 70 [ __ ]
sort of our kids in the back in jail
they had given up on themselves it's not
even a loser rat I never want to put you
here all right you put yourself here but
one man dared to take a risk you want to
start a football team
come on Shawn's impossible and let's try
the impossible and turn the rage that
made them enemies okay you right here
right now into a bond that could make
them brothers on the gridiron we're do
it my way your way got you here and
you're here because you lost if you
accept this challenge gonna be winners
you get out there you run their asses
over and don't quit you run the play do
it right you just get out there and give
it your best shot
hey Danielle you don't really want to
kiss anything about me trying to change
you can do it you hear me
[Music]
for your mom coach
and not the loser you were when you
first got here well you just not used to
be in a winner
now is the time to prove to yourselves
my son buddy Gridiron Gang that's why
we're here because we care cuz it's
showing the money
[Music]
there has always been a delicate balance
between chaos and control now with that
balance threatened it's time to turn to
one man how do I know you're not control
if I were control you'd already be dead
if you were controlled you'd already be
dead neither of us is dead so I'm
obviously not from control that actually
makes sense
he has learned the identities of all of
our field agents they hit us and they
hit us hard fortunately we have a new
agent who is that sir it's you max
Maxwell Smart for you
may 2 99 is this a stapler yeah
I set that up
[Music]
[Music]
miss it why that much
Tuesday's not gonna work him not due
Tuesday Shan Shan see how annoying that
is
[Music]